we have Alex poke off and Dan Connolly
I'll be talking
medical informatics and how to scrape up
all of our medic
make some use of it so let's welcome
them as welcome them thank you thank you
all right so hi I'm Dan Connolly and I'm
Alex spoke up and we're going to today
we're going to talk about using Python
and paper to control a large medical
informatics ETL process so I'm from the
University of Kansas Medical Center
mostly writing software to support
research all kinds of logos about my
past history the one that's most
relevant is and I'm software development
lead for this greater plains
collaborative which you'll hear more
about and me when I was 14 years old I
decided that I wanted to cure death
because you know why not um and you know
so what I went to school for a bunch of
time um you know got a PhD in physiology
and then it turned out that the real I
realized that the real limiting factor
is not collecting more data but making
sense of the data that's being collected
apparently there's fewer people willing
to grind up data than to grind up mice
so um you know back to the drawing board
I you know I'm okay with computers I you
know took took some more coursework in
applied statistics and now i am working
at the UT Health Science Center
Department of Epidemiology and
biostatistics attacking that same
problem from a bioinformatics point of
view of course grant review committees
don't like it when you sound crazy so
instead of saying I'm here to cure death
we call it the fight against cancer
heart disease neurodegeneration on
diabetes morbidity frailty but in the
end it's it's all one problem we um so
this the greater plains collaborative is
a is a group of ten academic hospitals
and clinics scattered sort of like down
the middle of the United States and
we're Dan and I are kind of a cross
section of the GPC dan comes from the
then comes from the middle of it from
from Kansas City where GPC was founded
and I come from the very edge from
whether from the newest GPC member site
dan knows a ton about software
engineering and I mostly try to keep up
with him so why mine medical data you
the the most obvious answer is why mine
any data there are some they're hidden
correlations their risk factors waiting
to be discovered simply because nobody
has been able to look there before and
i'll get to in a minute why nobody's
looked in medical records before at this
scale secondly feasibility studies are
there enough patients fitting a
particular criterion for you to be able
to do a clinical study on them and if
your study is feasible and let's say it
gets approved on this same tool can be
used for a physician to reach out to
patients who have a particular disease
and ask them if they're interested in
volunteering for a clinical trial and
finally um kind of sort of a recurring
theme probably throughout this meeting
is visualizing the data forming new
hypotheses sort of playing with the data
and okay but there are hurdles to be
overcome first of all we have to have
our queries have to run at an acceptable
speed to the users despite the size of
the data our queries have to yield
repeatable results despite the
ever-increasing complexity of the data
with each with each additional load and
finally we need to give our scientists
flexibility and independence in pursuing
their research without compromising on
patient privacy we can't just have them
tell us what they want done and have us
be there intermediaries to the greatest
extent we can we'd like for them for it
to be a self-service kind of operation
so when I'm talking about sighs we have
a kumc has 1.3 billion observations on 2
million patients and this has to the UM
they have to query over this you know
within minutes of
for some of the queries um when we're
talking about complexity we're pulling
data from a very diverse range of
sources many of them never intended to
be a data source for research you're
going to be hearing a lot about this top
left one this is um this is a database
known as clarity made by a company
called epic and it is widely used in
hospitals for patient billing and
patient records there's a number of
other data sources social security death
master file for example can can reveal
the ages of death for patients on the we
have biospecimen repositories we have
tumor registries and and in a constantly
growing list of data sources all of them
in different formats and they have to be
unified into a single repository that
can be queried from a single point and
when we're talking about patient privacy
so we are paranoid privacy geeks to
begin with and the industry we work in
kind of almost legally mandates that we
be that way be through a thorough number
of regulations including HIPAA the
health insurance portability and
accountability act in plain English it
means the data has to be securely it has
to be maintained securely use of this
data for any purpose other than you know
the its original intended one is subject
to IRB approval but if we can scrub the
data of identifying information
particularly patient IDs and dates um
this data is no longer human subject
data and we can make the researchers
lives easier because we apply for IRB
approval and then pass the data on to
them so they don't have to and so they
could concentrate on science and not on
bureaucracy so at the front end this is
the this is the system that we use to
overcome these hurdles and the user
interface to the system is something
called I to be too it's an open source
tool developed at Harvard for
a4a for use as a medical data repository
and when a researcher logs in to the
itv2 website this is what they see in
the top left panel um there are various
there are various terms now what I mean
by terms is really very general it's
almost anything you can observe about a
patient during a visit it could be
something like body weights like a
numeric variable it could be it could be
a categorical variables such as
ethnicity it could be a it could be a
binary flag like are they do they have a
particular diagnosis or not and there is
a large number of different
categorization schemes that can be
applied to the same data and all of them
are accessible through here so let's say
you want to select a group of patients
that have a set of characteristics you
find your terms in this hierarchical
list you drag them to the query
interface you run the query and you get
in and you get a result set so here each
of these sections is an individual
patient and within each section these
horizontal lines represent the different
variables that you are that your that
you've chosen on the stigma um and the
horizontal axis is time so you hear
you're following a patient and
observations are being made at various
times so for example this top variable
is BMI body mass index on this bottom
variable i is is our it is a hemoglobin
essay now you can't see the actual
values that were obtained at these
points but you know that data was
collected at those points for those
patients so um and at the back end this
data is stored in a star schema which is
common idiom in data warehouses on this
this in the middle you see and a fact
table each entry in this table
represents a particular observation made
about a particular patient during a
particular visit to a particular
healthcare provider and the remaining
table
oops concept codes to query terms that
the user can interact with okay so so
that's what pretty much comes out of the
box with with i2b2 what doesn't come out
of the box is software to load the data
into that star schema from the various
systems that we get it out of the
hospital records system etc so the way
we do that is we get the data from on
the left there the left there the
participating clinical systems the
hospital mainly we get sort of an Oracle
data dump of their stuff we load it into
on our side then we transform it into
the shape that I to be to wants to see
and load it and then we run that look
like you said scrubbing stuff to get the
identifiers and the dates fuzz and we
copy it to a whole no separate machine
and that's the database that's used at
runtime for researchers by the to run
their queries and one of the techniques
we use to make this whole thing work is
that while the scientists are using
database a in production we've got a
whole copy of that whole system there
that's connected to the itv2 software
and production and then while there
that's running the developers and stuff
in the bar in the back of the closet
filling up to be database from from this
month's ETL then when this month stuff
is already we flip and flop and we
connect the ITB sooo software to the new
data and then the developers start
running the ETL for the next month so
there's some trade-offs to this the
reason we do it is that we get a short
downtime on the order of an hour to
switch over instead of on the order of
50 hours which is how long the ETL job
takes to run and that's if it works well
so if it didn't work well then we would
have to continue to debug and all that
kind stuff and the whole system would be
offline so we go ahead and we bite the
bullet and we take the stew X storage
hit which is cheaper than the customer
and developer time even though we're
using fusion-io solid-state storage and
stuff
so big atl jobs like this there are some
tools out there on the market we took a
look at talent and pentaho we found some
kind of performance scalability issues
in them they didn't seem to be quite a
good match microsoft has this ssas tool
doesn't really match very well when most
of our data comes from oracle there's
oracle PL sequel which is a language i
guess a lot of people use for this I
didn't take a close look at that so we
didn't use any of those we ended up
developing our own but we did rent out
into some of the same features that they
provide we ended up needing a powerful
job control user interface some kind of
logging monitoring and testings the big
job runs lights out you want to know
what's going on and it turns out to get
kind of complex and so you do want the
visualization that that a lot of those
tools give you and major concern was the
ability to bring on new developers and
system administrators quickly so we
started with some sequel code we got
from peers in the IT developed itv2
developer community that load some of
the data from from epic to clarity
database and we just use Oracle sequel
developer tool and step through the code
manually line by line and then when I
thought about running this stuff lights
out for me I'm a sequel I mean I'm a
Python developer sequels the stuff that
goes between the quote marks right so I
was putting it in there and then well so
the guide the sequel developer on the
team you know he's not going to go into
the Python code and edit the stuff
between the quote marks that's a pain so
we put the sequel in the sequel files
and then the Python reads this the
sequel scripts and runs it and the
sequel really dominates here we've got
twenty thousand lines of sequel code
just about five lines five kilobytes
five thousand lines of Python so there's
a little function in the middle of the
thing that splits sequel scripts into
sequel statements it mostly just looks
for semicolons but you got to be careful
at the semicolon occurs in a comment or
a string constant something like that
okay so then you you get this great big
sequel script driven by Python and it
runs and takes a long time
and maybe it runs all the way to the end
or maybe it doesn't mean you gotta debug
part of it or maybe it's all working
great and you want to add something to
it well so it turns out you want to kind
of break this thing into chunks and so
what are we going to use as a job
control user interface well I'm a kind
of a long time UNIX guy command lines
good enough for me but how do we get how
are we going to arrange the thing in
parts well the job sort of looked like
make to me you have different make
targets and the one target depends on
another and i found a python package
called paver where it has these task
things and they look a little bit like
make file targets to me so you can say
paver hair and load and it'll go find
the hair and load in your function in
your code and you can give it
configuration parameters and stuff like
that a lot like make and you can have
dependencies between one task and
another you tell you ask it to we've got
this load epic labs task we've developed
any of you if you ask it to run that one
it knows to run the make epic labs of
use task first and you tell it the
relationship between the task spice by
when you define the load epic labs thing
you tell it that it needs that make epic
labs views task that's kind of what the
syntax looks like so then this is what
the what you want to visualize the
results you got to end up with a lot of
these tasks so here's a few of them
connected there's a few of more of them
connected and that's actually the whole
thing is 110 of these things and and we
had to debug some actual some cycles in
there that's really bad thing and when
we when we were able to look at the
whole thing like this we noticed that
some snarls in the code and we were able
to reorganize it really helped so how do
we get this picture it's kind of one of
the interesting tricks parsing Python
and getting all the dependencies you
know getting the toothpaste back in the
tube might look really difficult but
turns out that the Python standard
library has this abstract syntax tree
ast module and you just use that API and
it will call you back every time there's
a function definition so and all I do is
for every function definition I figure
out where the needs doodads on there and
it's another 15 or 20 lines to figure
out the dependencies between the tasks
and it writes it out in a coupling comma
separated values file and convert that
to the graph is format and and then it
builds these great big diagrams so we
get it all working and then boss comes
in and says we need allergies we didn't
have allergies next month we're going to
have allergies next month so this is our
development process so the first thing
we do is we try to say well okay what do
you mean we want to use allergies and
and and he says well we got to research
it he wants to know for example how many
patients get hives from penicillin
alright so that's a that's a use case I
can sink my teeth into and so now I go
looking through the 6,000 tables and
clarity and I go truck and look through
their documentation their data
dictionary etc and I find the allergy
data and I write some sequel queries and
I eventually find out I figure out where
the data is to answer this question
about how many patients get hives from
penicillin and all the other allergic
reactions and all the other allergens
etc so then we write a little bit more
code to transform this into the shape
that I to be to expects and the terms
stuff and then so now you're sort of
running the stuff interactively then you
got to do a little bit more software
engineering to get it to run lights out
with automated testing and such so one
of the forms of testing we do you might
find a constraint it looks like it's
there in the data it's really not in the
sequel schema and so what we do is we go
okay well it's there's none of these
patients over 90 today but I want to
make sure there's no patients over 90
when it's running lights out when I'm
not around so we write this sequel
statement where if there are any
patients over 90 years old which is
against the rules for the identification
it'll divide by zero and it's kind of
like an assertion test okay so for
example suppose we're rolling back in
time and we're just going to do labs
what we want to do is get the data out
of the clarity stuff is on the list
that's the hospital database then we're
going to transform it and put it into
the identified star schema and then
we're going to de-identify it and put it
into the idea identified stuff on the
right
and the first half of that going from
clarity to the eye to be to shape so
here's the reminder the ITB to scheme oh
we're trying to get it into something
that looks like that especially that
middle table so we select from the
relevant clarity tables here's the
social so this is a not labs this is
social history so we've got the smoking
tobacco use table and such like that and
so we go find the relevant tables and
the relevant relevant part of clarity
that's analogous to the encounter number
in I to be too likewise for patient
number concept code is a particularly
interesting one for this one this is the
actual tobacco status etc there's a few
others they're straightforward start
date etc okay and then we have the gray
box observation fact lab or being out in
the and now just for social history so
that gives us into the shape that I to
be too is interested in and then we load
it into the database correlating
patients with correlating the data on
paint by patient with data from other
sources there's essentially a fact table
start we start out with a fact table for
each data source sometimes several facts
tables for each data source and we glob
them all together by patient into a
unified fact table that then becomes
that one that Dan just showed right so
that goes into the identified stuff and
then we runs a big policy quell not a
great big pile of seagull hundred lines
of sequel or whatever to shift the dates
and such okay that's so that second part
the first part sorry the first part we
got to write special code like this for
social hurt social history another one
for labs another one for meds like that
the second half sorry the second half of
getting the loading the data in and
correlating the patients we just have
one hunk of sequel and we just
substitute in the the name right there
at epic fact view that's one of these
sort of a macro that we've adopted from
Oracle sequel plus but we use mostly the
same hunk of sequel and we just replace
this this one little variable
there and run it over and over so that's
one of the kind of features that I
couldn't find in those ETL tools okay so
after you pull your hair out and do
whatever you finally get the thing to
work and the query works and you've got
your number of patients and this
previous queries thing ITB to actually
44 just reuse and for auditing purposes
it saves an XML representation in your
query and it saves the generated sequel
that it actually used to run the query
so we've got a little capture query
utility that goes and grabs that out of
the audit tables and saves it in our
test data set and then we've got another
test hair and query thing that at
release time we go rerun all these
queries and make sure they still work
okay so then you've done all that
development then you check with one of
your peers on the team and you see you
know is this code that they would be
willing to maintain there's a few other
things on our checklist about you know
is the code dry and such like this and
if if everybody's happy then you check
it into the production and on we go
month to month month the month and as of
January we were up to 35 consecutive
monthly updates to the whole system with
new data every month and usually some a
few neat new features every month so the
whole thing is it's going along
reasonably well along the way pretty
recently we've introduced continuous
integrations using Jenkins I'm not a big
Java guy but this thing you can install
almost by mistake when you know we're
looking it's really easy so every time
there's a commit and push we run all the
unit tests hourly there's a monitoring
query that makes sure that well it tries
to make sure that we find out before the
customers do if the whole thing falls
over daily we run an integration test
build with a small set of a few hundred
patients test data test patients daily
we run we take our performance sweet and
we don't actually run the whole
performance sweet but we check that the
we do in explain plan on make sure that
plans execution plans have not changed
then weekly we run sort of a one-percent
or maybe half percent sample of the
whole production data and rerun the
whole performance sweet and actually
measure the time
alright so logging I mentioned is kind
of important with lights out you want to
find out what was going on there and
paver has some logging support to sort
glorified print statements and and this
worked ok but I got tired of grapping
the log files and stuff like that and I
explored some alternatives the Python
configurable logging API gets you a
certain distance I tried maybe the
Jenkins X unit tests user interface and
ended up writing some code this nested
event stuff that relates you've got one
statement in a sequel scripts that's
part of the the script as a whole and so
I want to be able to see the
relationship between those things in the
logs so that was this nested events
thing and ended up spitting out the logs
with just a little bit of formatting to
make him kind of separated values so you
double the quote marks and put some
commas in there and what you get is
something you can gloat into Excel and
filter just for the database connections
or just for the errors or just for the
things of this course or you can even do
our plots or Python or whatever there's
very little Python scripts that filter
the thing I've got a log outline i can
show if somebody wants to ask a question
about it this is the plot that we use to
you know which things take a long time
out of this for 50 hours so we can
figure out whether we should optimize
that or if it's just a lot of data okay
so earlier we visualize the task
dependencies but that actually doesn't
show you the data dependencies
completely so how did we get the data
dependencies this was kind of a fun
exercise turn out there's a sequel
parser that's one of the examples in the
pie parsing package by paul mcguire
require it only did select and it was
only for sequel light so i did insert
and update and the rest of those things
and expanded it for crazy Oracle things
like connect by and out comes the CSV
verse and the data dependencies where
was the dependency and what was the
source and the date of the destination
of it and outcomes those name we run it
through graph is and outcomes these
diagrams which is pretty cool so that's
pretty much the etl approach it's it's a
little non-traditional in some places
but we find it's workable some of the
tools try
to shield you from from sequel we
embrace it at the end of the day you're
going to have it at least in the coat in
the corners using those tools and we
just figure what the heck and we exploit
general-purpose programming language
Python version with that way we can use
with all the good traditional tools
version control unit testing we don't
have a user interface that's a diagram
for building the the job but we do get
the visualizations they are available as
a byproduct the training and team
scaling experience has been largely
positive we started out with myself and
one other guy on the team and now we're
up to on the order of five developers at
K med center and you know two three
additional sites joining including mine
and now it now this ETL process is being
developed at multiple sites and we're
moving toward a a robust well they have
and we're moving toward a robust secure
a clinical data warehouse all right so
we're getting our patient and our
researchers are getting some fun stuff
and our patients are still reasonably
secure we think and so here on you know
on one future direction is exporting
data into our for for more sort of
granular analytic soul of course this
can be done in and numpy and and and you
know that that's that's also kind of a
on the agenda here you see some sort of
toy survival curves plotted within our
and and then rendered back on the eye to
be to a screen so and yeah yeah so while
i was developing that among some of the
other pieces of code as they as the
python code starts to get larger so
pythons great for little things and
stuff like that but as it starts to get
larger I start to wonder and my
teammates start to gripe a little bit
about the ability to read the code with
all the types left and plis it and what
I want to refactor the code I know I got
to go through and find all the
occurrences of something and replace it
do I have enough tests to make sure I've
got them all and turns out i had a kind
of a hobby project where i was
converting something from python to
scala and it ended up defining this kind
of as a byproduct this well
types dialogue of dialect of Python
where if you kind of avoid a few Python
dynamic idioms like keyword arguments
you what you end up with is completely
reliable parameter type documentation
and you never miss another rename when
you're refactoring and there's no latent
tightness matches in just a little teeny
preview of this so the there's a piece
of Python that glues i2b2 an R and it
kind of handles some web stuff right and
so here's your typical piece of Python
to handle some web stuff this is using
the traditional wsgi and everybody knows
the types of the env and start response
parameters right so if you're a good boy
you've write them down anyway you say
that the environment is the dictionary
they should be request headers maybe and
the return type is a sequence of strings
so all we need to do to use this tool is
to write down the types in a slightly
more formal way use Scala syntax it
turns out and then you run the pie to
skeletool and then you run the results
through the Scala compiler and that
actually tells you if you've got any
type errors or typos and stuff so that
was kind of a fun thing and it pretty
much just uses the existing conventions
it's not too far so you can still run
the results through sphinx and you get
nice looking documentation alright so
we've liked on behalf of our teams back
home would like to thank them and
especially the nurses and physicians who
are really doing the hard work and even
more especially the patients who is who
are what we're altima tlie doing this
all for all right we got just a couple
minutes for some questions thank you
in the back Oh
oh alright I'll ask question oh okay you
mentioned something very interesting in
the beginning data changes constantly so
two questions about this a how do you
how much your data change is because you
said your predictions should be
approximately the same according to the
changes of data so how much are they the
same are the same every month every year
it's the first question second question
is what are you going to do for the
future because there'll be streams of
data coming from all sorts of other
devices that you don't see now so are
you planning for that on the first
question how much do things change
there's boy that's a so the hospital is
rolling out the electronic medical
record system so some of the clinics are
using it and some of them are not
they're using it for some things and not
for others anyway there's lose
operational things like that just the
data you know we get a few more patients
that we go from 1.1 million to 1.1
million to 1.2 million the labs grows
from so many to so many we one of the q
HX we do is to make sure it's more every
month so usually sometimes like our
ethnicity information went down one
month and we had to go talk to the
hospital people what's going on they
were representing the data differently
so you know you can imagine the problems
there do we have a limit for growth the
growth is may be limited by hardware or
something I don't know but that's we're
not really close to the limits there as
to the future we've got that development
process we've incorporated new things
every month for 35 months it's that's
kind of our process in our plan that's
as far as we can see forward so have a
question so it's really resting watching
the Python watching Python and his tools
progress through different communities
sort of started with I don't know what
it went to sign to the computing you see
in financing ads and data processing and
also sort of landing and medical
informatics but can you guys talk a
little bit about the community as there
is our community in Python the medical
X is that growing other tools as sort of
pioneers what do you find in that space
there is I'm pretty sure so I don't
there's there's biomedical informatics
with the talks about pulse and diagnosis
and all that kind of stuff and then
there's bioinformatics that talks about
a's and GS and T's and C's and and that
kind of stuff and the bioinformatics
community is big on there's Python stuff
all over the place there but I'll go
ahead we're sort of we're certainly
trying to to to build a medical
informatics community around Python and
and there's it's it's in some ways
there's there's a bit of a culture gap
between the sort of the very uptight
kind of very very formal and and and you
know attitude of of of the medical
establishment and sort of the D hacker
ethic of the of the you know the many of
the Python developers yeah I'm a long
time web guy so every time I put two
brain cells together it's on the web and
then I ran into somebody at a conference
that was working in the bio the life
sciences and he was like you showed
somebody before it was published you
know yeah very different approaches one
more quick question yeah quick question
so of your system today like what is one
of the things you would most like to
improve about it like what do you think
the the weakest er most annoying spotted
full disclosure I'm not entirely sure
about paver frankly we've sort of
abstracted the use of paver more and
more out the guy who developed paver I
think is sort of end-of-life didn't and
moved on to something else and I wonder
about that approach and what I'm trying
to do while I still remember what it's
like to not know any of this stuff and
look and have this sinking feeling in my
stomach when I see that dependency graph
is to document as many of the questions
I had that got answered for the next
developer because that's and in general
I think that's a heuristic you should do
when you're learning something for the
first time remember
what it is you didn't know because
that's what the next people are also
going to be stumped by and you have this
unique super power as a noob if you're a
noob it's something and everyone's anew
but something to to to write useful
documentation that people who know too
much about it are no longer capable of
writing that's a great point the the
expertise of the novice okay let's uh
let's give them a round of applause
maybe thanks everybody and a few minutes
left west McKenney oh all right thank
you